hello reject nation we're starting to
film this video
I'm Greg Alba what this is perfect that
you point that out because we're going
to watch a movie clip Wow I know right
the pipes on Greg tonight can I see that
voice we're gonna watch a movie clip
called can you go a bit higher I show
Lisa the trailer for this movie before
we started filming this one so she was a
little listen guys before we go into
this I want to thank everyone who's been
joining our patreon page and becoming a
patron eject means the world to me over
there we got TV show reactions for many
of shows including attack on Titan my
hero academia Gotham Riverdale Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood supernatural
and we also do weekly q and A's so thank
you very much as our patron pages are
going up a lot and we post so much over
there arguably more on there that we do
an ear to killing it come on patron jack
today I love I love the commentary it's
only a minute long okay make it happen
make it happen
uno dos tres whoa
oh yeah can you go a bit higher I do any
high are any dogs who hear me
[Music]
kind of makes you wanna try
[Applause]
he's really embracing it man look at him
go
God you know what I've been loving about
it why didn't they show the whole movie
right there I thought this was free on
YouTube what I've been loving so much
about loving so much about how they've
been promoting this movie and I hope
it's the representative way in the
actual film this whole movie feels like
just an awesome concert music a lot of
times you see biopics especially of
famous musicians or bands and they're
usually the most depressing piece of
material ever like it's like sex
addiction and drug addicts and he had a
wild lifestyle and he died of a very
unfortunate situation what I love is
this movie seems to be honoring what
made him a legend what man
famous was the music like even seeing
the breakdown and the crazy method of
like just repeat Galileo and keep going
higher you know artists I have a feeling
people are gonna be like singing in the
theater as they're watching it like like
a big sing-along with strangers it's
gonna feel like a concert yeah because I
saw this trailer at the IMAX theater and
watching him on that scope was like wow
I just be seeing the stadium and putting
you back in there because it looks like
they're really gonna let the the scenes
where is performing the concert really
go on also this breakdown and study it
seems like it's really about the music
music I feel like well they'll touch on
this personal life they'll touch on the
struggles I'm sure that you you have to
I'm really intrigued of the idea of just
making this kind of a tribute film of
the artistry and the passion and the
crazy methods this guy had because you
know Queen is not traditional music
there's not but it's loved by so many
people of all ages you know what I mean
it's like timeless it's very timeless
it's time
[Applause]
and his performance just looks just
excellent when I'm watching the trailer
it seems to have a lot of style a lot of
editing a lot of craziness and then
watching just like a 30-second scene of
them breaking it down there's a lot of
great visual imagery here oh yeah
and it looks like a wide variety of
shots that are all within this one
location you like him seen him in the
booth other guys mixing and recording
and you're getting a bunch of different
angles from this with a bunch of crazy
different edits it seems like it's very
methodical and thought-out
the directing approach seems to be in
tune with the singing yeah yeah and like
every like the actors everyone they're
amazing you know but you seem to forget
like the director and like people
creating the shots and all like they're
amazing - oh yeah seems to be doing an
amazing job with this working together
this looks so beautiful I can't wait to
see it can't wait to see I can't wait to
see it you want to go see it yeah yeah
let's go see it and then we'll watch a
horror movie oh no no thanks yondu
horror it's very tough for me you know
you don't have the personality where I'd
pick up on this well speaking of British
singers I want to give a page for the
day shadow to a lovely woman named
Victoria Huntley Victoria there's all
the way in the UK she's been in part of
our patron page for a while and I've
talked with her quite a bit she kind of
has like a geeky personality which I
love about her keeping the tradition of
talking about love going with Lisa she
is actually engaged she even sent me
this hahaha even sent me this website to
word that what he's gonna be happening
and she's getting married to a lovely
gentleman named Ricky no I know I'm not
not like my user Victoria you're ruining
the shout out Lisa I know I said keeping
the theme of talking about love with
Lisa going Victoria's getting engaged
I'm sorry Victoria I just wanted to
congratulate you and you're ruining my
toast
sounds like why are you saying no to all
this stuff no
getting married no you shouldn't feel
bad at all it's just a miscommunication
here and I don't believe in retail so
Victoria yeah trust me YouTube's our
Victoria but the name like Huntley it
sounds like you have hunted down the
right man for you I am so happy you're
gonna get married and I hope that one of
these days I can meet you guys
maybe if you're looking for a third
party on your honeymoon night in the
hotel room if you need someone to you
know fulfill that third party position
leases your girl
Barbie wha me you know Ricki sounds like
a handsome gentleman have you seen him
no but but the way she's describing big
license guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation what do you think about
him Ian Rhapsody he clicked that
notification Bell
check us out patreon Lisa mihalick
please check out her YouTube channel and
follow her on Instagram as well I do so
you should that's a good plug right
sayonara ladies and gents
that was interesting